hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute gibt es wieder was
leckeres mediterranes und zwar gibt es
heute eine leckere hauptspeise und ich
mache jetzt heute nur die hauptspeise
aber wir servieren später noch reis dazu
und mein video für den türkischen reizt
den ich so gerne mache
den bekommt ihr einfach beim nächsten
mal ich zeige ich jetzt einfach mal die
zutaten
ich habe hier 500 gramm hackfleisch das
ist jetzt rinder hackfleisch das war
eingefroren und ich hab das dann einfach
in kaltem wasser auftauen lassen und
hauptsitz ausgepackt wir brauchen etwas
olivenöl eine zwiebel pfeffer hier habe
ich 200 gramm mehl und davon vier
esslöffel mehl einfach mal weg gelegt
sage ich euch später warum ich brauche
ein paar gewürze also neben dem pfeffer
brauche ich noch salz etwas chili
mintzel und oregano dann traurig 2 bis 3
knoblauchzehen ich habe jetzt nur zwei
weil die zwei relativ groß sind zwei
esslöffel tomatenmark ein paar
kichererbsen ich habe jetzt die aus der
dose weil die schon gekocht sind und ich
die nicht extra kochen muss und wir
brauchen noch einen liter wasser und den
saft einer zitrone aus den zutaten mache
ich jetzt ein leckeres hauptgericht und
zwar wenn es so kleine
hackfleischbällchen in tomatensoße und
dieses gericht heißt auf türkisch milas
kräfte und me lässt es sich einfach so
eine region in der türkei eine stadt in
der türkei in der region molise und bot
nun und isoliert ist mir genau da in der
nähe ist es und da wir das gerne gemacht
und das machen wir jetzt heute eben bei
uns zu hause in waghäusel
ich nehme jetzt die zwiebel und schreibe
die ganz fein können dann natürlich auch
einfach in den mixer klein machen
die türkei ist auch so dass viele
erreger nach der region benannt nach der
stadt königstein stiftung als auch oder
königsberger klopse nur mit tomaten in
anderen ländern auch dass du einfach ins
bett
ich ziehe jetzt handschuhe an weil ich
jetzt gleich das fleisch verkneten muss
und ihr könnt es natürlich auch mit der
hand machen aber bei fleisch habe ich
irgendwie immer gern handschuh an und es
vergeht ich jetzt kurz hier mit den
zwiebeln hat sich halt auch nicht so
appetitlich angehen dass jetzt herr
lecker jetzt gebe ich das salz dazu etwa
einem teelöffel
und mein mann muss mir ganz kurz helfen
mit der promille war ein bisschen das
reicht einfach eine gute prise pfeffer
und jetzt gebe ich da noch das glas mit
dem mehl rhein und die vier esslöffel
hab ich ja schon weg gelegt und das
hilft dann einfach dass man da welche
bindungen reinkriegen müssen ja so macht
man es eigentlich in deutschen rezepten
die türkei halt mail das ist auch okay
sagte meine mutter schwer und wir haben
immer alles gemacht
ihr seid ehrgeizig und wollte es nicht
wegschmeißen
ich hoffe ich schaffe
ich habe jetzt nicht das komplette mail
rein also 50 km jetzt bei mir noch übrig
einfach weil es schon eine ziemlich
feste masse ist und jetzt gebe ich hier
die vier esslöffel mehl einfach eine
kleine schale und nehme jetzt das
fleisch und machte einfach kleine
portionen raus müssen jetzt kugeln die
haben jetzt etwa so 152 cm im
durchmesser und sind etwa zum haselnuss
bis wahl muss groß und die gebe ich da
jetzt rein
das rezept erinnert mich übrigens immer
an den film susi und strolch da essen
sie doch auch in der pizzeria oder eben
beim italiener so von spaghetti rezept
und das sind auch diese fleischküchle
mit dabei er wollte als kind immer das
gleiche es zu diesen anderen disney für
wolkig mit aussicht auf fleischbällchen
öffnet ihr einfach so ein bisschen hin
und her schütteln und dann werden die
richtig gut gewählt
meine bändchen sind jetzt alle geformt
und ich werde jetzt hier in eine pfanne
etwas olivenöl geben so etwa 13 s klasse
und da werde ich wieder die bällchen
drin braten zu schnell weg
sehr groß und man
hackfleisch
nur mal gerne auch noch machen
wir passen jetzt sogar alle rein und die
werden jetzt einfach rundherum knusprig
gebraten und dieses restliche mädel des
schweißens weg des brauches gleich für
die soße aber zuerst sprachen wir jetzt
mal die welt kennt meine hackbällchen
sind jetzt gebrabbel ich habe auch schon
eine probiert das stimmt salz und
pfeffer stimmt alles von den gewürzen
her nicht stellt es jetzt ganz kurz auf
die seite
und neben mir zu den kochtopf und wird
darin jetzt weitermachen da gebe ich
jetzt auch noch mal drei esslöffel
reichen drei esslöffel öl rein
die knoblauchzehen werden da reingeraten
ihr könnt natürlich auch eine
knoblauchpresse nehmen aber gegeben sind
sehr auch ganz schnell
noch hat es gibt gleich essen die
branche ist ja nicht alles weg ist
liebt den geruch von knoblauch
mein mann erlitt
da bist jetzt aufpassen dass der
knoblauch nicht anbrennt also lieber mal
den herzlichen runterschalten und stark
gebe ich jetzt auch das mehl mit dazu
bester schütze für die bindung für die
soße zuständig ich bin kein mensch der
so knoblauch fanatischen die essener mit
wenn ihr merkt er zu wenig öl einfach
nur ein bisserl dazugeben sind jetzt
auch eine große menge und die knoblauch
max kraftvoll in den augen
und wenn es um bisschen angebraten ist
gebe ich hier noch die zwei esslöffel
tomatenmark mit rein
die ist natürlich erst öffnen muss ich
hätte jetzt gedrückt und gedrückt
menschen mich gebucht gebraten schaltet
wieder ein bisserl hoch
so wie knoblauch schlägt meine augen
brennen von dem ganzen problems sich das
mit dem einen meter wasser ab geh mal
auf höchster stufe damit dass hier schön
kochen kann
ich nehme jetzt auch mal ein schneebesen
das kurz aufkochen willst das ganze dann
kommen die fleischbällchen rein und dann
immer fertig die soße kocht jetzt noch
nicht dies jetzt hier noch kurz die
kichererbsen ab in samira sieg wenn die
das sehen wird witze wieder schimpfen
aber ich nehme da jetzt nur die hälfte
also ich nehme nur die hälfte der dose
mit der anderen hälfte kammer zum
beispiel ganz leckere sachen machen wie
wichtig auch bei schaufelt nur blog drin
die hälfte dazu und jetzt kommen da auch
noch die fleischbällchen rein
die gebe ich am besten so rein dass
jetzt nicht so spritzt die sind jetzt
nicht mehr so heiß
jetzt ist ganz so gut durchrühren und
würzen ich gebe da jetzt noch salz mit
rein ich habe zwar salz in den
hackbällchen aber die soße muss ja auch
jetzt gewürzt werden nochmals man nicht
zu viel also ein teelöffel dürfte
reichen dann natürlich fahren wer frau
muss immer sein
chilli ich mach mir zuviel kann ja jeder
nach witzen und stand noch oregano und
minze so etwas essen
verrühren mit das schön und ich lasse es
jetzt noch einmal aufkochen und so etwa
15 minuten köcheln
dann ist sie so sind fertig in der zeit
mache ich schon mal meinen reis und dann
kann was servieren
meine soße ist jetzt gekocht und
gekuschelt und die hackbällchen sind
richtig schön durchgegart entschuldigung
kochen samira marktes wort köcheln nicht
und da gebe ich jetzt noch den
zitronensaft mit dazu
ich nehme es aber nur die hälfte war die
irgendwie so mega groß sind
sie sind sogar so groß dass presse passt
zu groß zu tun auch nicht aber ist die
g-star an
ich war jetzt beim türken und er hat
natürlich keine video zu tun gehabt
na wie er die neben atomkraftwerk leben
haben die zitronen natürlich bei uns
besonders groß mit tanz zitronen sollte
einmal abspecken und wenn da irgendwie
noch was fehlt säure oder salz pfeffer
könnte das jetzt noch dazu geben
mein größter kritiker poster kann
stellte
hmm
finds gut
gut da und wir servieren das ganze jetzt
so etwas reis und deswegen gebe ich da
jetzt die bällchen mir dazu schaut dann
deine fraktion die schon so groß wie
kriegst du
und so lassen wir uns das jetzt gleich
schmecken ich finde es schmeckt auf
jeden fall celica vor allerdings auch
was für kinder weil diese fleisch wissen
so richtig süß aussehen und das rezept
ich auch gar nicht schwer zu machen
es ist sehr schnell hergestellt ich habe
jetzt etwa eine halbe bis
dreiviertelstunde gebraucht nebenher
habe ich noch reis gekocht und es geht
alles auf jeden fall ganz fix und salat
können jetzt auch noch dazu machen und
dann nicht unser menü komplett für heute
ich hoffe dass ich das rezept gefallen
hat und hoffe dass sie erstmal
nachkochen werdet ihr könnt natürlich
auch stadt der kita erbsen zum beispiel
ohne nehmen
köcheln lässt nicht es heißt kochen
genau und ihr könnt mir einfach mal
sagen wir euch dieses rezept gefallen
hat und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten
mal wieder bis bald